[Applause]
contest Amisha Assenmacher says volvo is
latin for by rule the cars are a Swedish
make where safety is writ large but her
test car is not so much about safety
this time as about something else
entirely
it's about pure sporting fun the v60
Polestar is the most powerful station
wagon Volvo has ever produced in series
the 2-liter direct fuel-injection
gasoline engine from volvo v60 t6 AWD
has been modified to put out 270
kilowatts the Polestar makes the sprint
from 0 to 100 km/h and a sizzling 4.8
seconds its maximum speed is
electronically capped at 250 km/h sho
equips that the v60 Polestar doesn't say
I roll so much as make way
I'm coming Volvo and Pulstar took up
their cooperation about 20 years ago in
2015 Volvo acquired the company so now
Polestar is for Volvo a bit like what
AMG is for Mercedes the show would never
have thought driving a Volvo could be so
exciting aside from the color in the
Polestar emply key on the back she
thinks the Polestar looks rather
garden-variety from the outside but
personally she likes it it's a wolf in
sheep's clothing if you like
the front has been kept rather plain and
ordinary but there are some unique
features that make the car look a bit
sportier such as the blue pull star
badge on the glossy black grille the
standard dual scent on headlights can
also be noted here a length of four
point 64 meters with a wheelbase of two
point 78 meters makes for plenty of room
for five occupants in the Polestar a new
rear spoiler also makes for a sporty
touch along with the twin integrated
tailpipes and a new diffuser to set it
apart from its tamer siblings
[Music]
if your mission for shell feels really
comfortable in the v60 Polestar it's
spacious the steering wheel sits in her
hands incredibly well partly thanks to
the materials and partly because of the
shape but she concedes that the button
layout is a little dated the switches
and knobs are just a bit too far away
for convenience a heated steering wheel
and backlit gearshift knob are also
standard in the Polestar blue stitching
gives the interior a fresh note
[Music]
in Germany the poll stars around 17,000
euros more expensive than the t6 AWD
it's based on but that includes the
modified 8-speed automatic transmission
and suspension equipped with special
dampers and stiffer springs at first
Michelle was a bit nervous about pushing
the Polestar in two curves on wet roads
but it took them quite nicely though she
noticed it understeers in front but
she's still having fun driving it the
pool star makes no compromises on the
safety and drivers assistance systems
these include automatic emergency
braking with pedestrian detection a
Driver Alert control and a Lane Keeping
Assist among others
this can involve Michelle had always
thought a vulval as a conservative car
maker but the v60 Polestar showed her
its sporty-er and especially its louder
side she never expected the Swedes to
come out with a car like this
so she's positively surprised she thinks
it's quite expensive but the price gets
you good workmanship and more driving
fun which she's now off to test-drive a
little more